دعوه من كاس العالم 2022 حيث ضرب منتخب
الارجنتين موعد ناريا مع منتخب هولندا بعد
تاهلهما الى الدور الثمانيه حقيقه
الارجنتين فوزا صعبا على منتخب استراليا
بهدفين مقابل هدف في المباراه الامس
بتاريخ ميسي حيث سجل هدفه التاسع في
المونديال متفوقا على الراحل جيكو
مارادونا بينما انتصرت هولندا على منتخب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بثلاثه اهداف
مقابل هدف واحد المزيد حول اهداف ميسي
[تصفيق]
مع وصوله للمباراه رقم 1000 في مسيرته
الاحترافيه سجل الارجنتيني ليونيل ميسي
العديد من الارقام الخاصه به مع منتخب
بلاده النجم الارجنتيني سجل الهدف التاسع
خلال مشاركته الخامسه في كاس العالم
متجاوزا دييغو مارادونا ليصبح على بعد هدف
من مواطنه غابريول باتيستوتا هدف ميسي
امام امريكا كان اول اهدافه في ادوار خروج
المغلوب في كاس العالم حيث كانت كل
اهدافها السابقه في دوري المجموعات ميسي
سجل هدفه السابع بالقدم اليسرى خلال
مشاركته في كاس العالم ليصبح على بعده هدف
واحد من البرازيليه صاحب ثمانيه اهداف
بالقدم اليسرى في المونديال وبالنسبه
للارجنتين فان الفوز على استراليا
ظفر بكاس العالم كل من فاز على منتخب
الكاميرون قبل ذلك مثل المانيا في مونديال
74 وايطاليا في 2006 وفرنسا في 2018
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]